Transcription: Line Alladoum
Relecteur: eric vautier
Aujourd’hui,
je vais vous parler d’histoire.
Mais comme j’ai un ego assez développé,
je vais d’abord vous
parler de mon histoire.
Quand j’étais petite, je regardais
souvent le ciel et les étoiles
en me demandant de quelle planète
je pouvais bien venir.
Je me sentais extrêmement différente.
J’avais l’impression d’être
une extraterrestre et je détestais ça.
Je souffrais énormément
du regard des autres,
alors j’ai étudié
le fonctionnement des humains
comme une ethnologue, pour pouvoir leur
ressembler et me fondre dans la masse.
J’ai fait tout ce que je pouvais
pour être la plus normale possible.
Personne ne savait réellement qui j'étais.
Je me montrais seulement quand j’étais
capable de compenser ma différence
pour passer inaperçue.
Je croyais que si je me montrais
telle que j’étais,
je n’aurais pas d’avenir.
Et c’est finalement cette croyance-là
qui a failli me tuer.
Tout ça m’épuisait.
J’étais de plus en plus déprimée
et mal dans ma peau.
Et surtout, j’étais en train
de me perdre totalement moi-même.
Et à force de me renier
et de me suradapter,
j’ai fini par faire un gros burn-out.
Mais je me souviens du jour
où j’ai vraiment touché le fond.
J’étais hospitalisée en psychiatrie
depuis des mois.
J’étais désespérée.
Je me demandais chaque jour
quand tout ça allait enfin s’arrêter.
Je ne voyais plus l’intérêt
de me soigner ni de m’en sortir.
Mais ce jour-là, ce vendredi 18 juin 2018,
je me suis prise pour Martin Luther King
et j’ai eu un rêve.
J'ai rêvé de pouvoir vivre dans un monde
où on a le droit d'être différent.
J’ai rêvé de pouvoir créer un projet
qui me servirait à mettre
mon expérience à profit
pour aider les personnes
à s’accepter, à aimer leurs différences,
à dépasser leurs difficultés et à faire
de leurs particularités une force.
Alors, j’ai pris un cahier super beau
et des stylos de plein
de couleurs différentes
et j’ai commencé à noter
toutes les idées qui me passaient
par la tête pour mon projet.
J’alternais le travail thérapeutique
et le travail sur mon projet.
Et plus j’avançais sur ce projet,
mieux je me sentais.
J’avais un pourquoi,
une motivation, une raison de m’en sortir,
connectée à quelque chose
de tellement important pour moi
que mes soucis avec le regard des autres
étaient déjà bien loin.
Je me suis reconnectée à moi-même
et j’ai appris à me connaître.
Je me suis enfin acceptée et j’ai commencé
à vivre en accord avec moi-même.
J’étais persuadée de me retrouver seule,
mais je préférais encore être rejetée
par le monde entier que continuer
à me renier davantage.
Mais à ma grande surprise, mes relations
avec les autres sont devenues
de plus en plus faciles.
J’ai cherché à comprendre pourquoi
et j’ai repensé à cette phrase
que l’on connaît tous.
« On ne peut pas plaire à tout le monde. »
Et cette phrase, je l'ai vue autrement.
Et je pense que
si on est d’accord pour dire
qu’on ne peut pas plaire à tout le monde,
ça veut aussi forcément dire
qu’on ne peut pas non plus
déplaire à tout le monde.
Alors c’est génial.
On ne peut pas déplaire à tout le monde.
Soyons nous-mêmes, ça nous permettra
d’attirer à nous des personnes
qui nous correspondent vraiment,
avec qui on se sent bien,
et de pouvoir nouer
des relations profondes et sincères.
Personnellement, m’accepter m’a permis
de rencontrer mon associé
avec qui c’est un réel plaisir
de partager un projet commun
autour d’un thème qui nous tient à cœur.
Pour mettre à profit mon expérience,
je me suis formée
au développement personnel,
au coaching et à l’arthérapie.
Ça me permet aujourd’hui d’aider
les personnes que j’accompagne
à s’aimer, à accepter leurs différences,
à dépasser leurs difficultés
et à faire de leur particularité une force
qui peut apporter au plus grand nombre.
Le fait d’avoir dû analyser en permanence
mon environnement
et le comportement des gens,
me permet aujourd’hui
de mieux comprendre les personnes,
de trouver facilement
leurs points forts, leurs particularités
et ce qu’elles peuvent en faire
en fonction de leur tempérament.
Et finalement, le fait de voir le monde
d'une façon différente m'apporte souvent
des solutions originales
aux problématiques.
Mais ce qui me plaît par-dessus tout,
c’est de transformer mon histoire
de façon positive
et d'en faire quelque chose qui peut
apporter aux autres et à l'histoire,
parce que chacune
de nos petites histoires personnelles
façonne l’histoire de l’humanité.
En acceptant d’être différent
et de se comporter différemment,
on peut, chacun à notre niveau,
influencer le cours de l’histoire.
Alors, soyons tous des petits
Martin Luther King.
Parlons de nos rêves et du monde
dans lequel on voudrait vivre
et servons-nous
de nos histoires personnelles
pour écrire l’histoire de demain.
Et toi, alors,
que vas-tu faire de ton histoire ?